the jurogan experience and this is the
same guy that just passed
this [ __ ] law in new york city where
you have to have a vaccine passport
to go everywhere you have to have a
vaccine to go
to a restaurant to a gym to
any place where people gather it is
crazy and meanwhile
the vast perce the biggest percentage of
people that
don't have vaccines or have been
vaccinated are people of color
so this guy people of color and
immigrants the
this is what he's always supposed to be
pro
you know pro people of color pro
diversity pro-immigration
those are the people that don't have
vaccines and now you're precluding them
from going to gyms
and restaurants and what about the
people working in the restaurants what
about all these
it's [ __ ] madness and then you have a
bunch of people that are supporting it
like yay
finally meanwhile you have sciences
coming out there's
legitimate articles jamie i'll send this
to you now there's legitimate art
because
doctors have been sending me these
things and you know this is neither
pro nor con vaccine i'm not this is not
a judgment statement
but imperfect vaccination can enhance
the transmission of
highly virulent pathogens right so this
is a scientific paper
um from 2015
that shows
that if here's a
there's this one important quote
vaccines that keep
the host alive but still allow
transmission
can thus allow virulent strains to
circulate in a population
so vaccines that
don't kill the virus vaccines that allow
people
like this is one of the things we're
finding out about what they're calling
breakthrough cases
right so people who are vaccinated can
still get covered
and they can still transmit kobe this
recently happened at the comedy store
a vaccinated comedian gave kovid to like
12 different [ __ ] people to comedy
store
some of them vaccinated some of them not
that situation where the vaccine just
kind of protects you from serious
damage right but it protects you from
really being
like badly hospitalized or death
but doesn't stop you from getting the
virus can
possibly lead to more potent viruses
so these people that are saying
oh it's these unvaccinated people that
are responsible for the variance
well there's actually scientific papers
that point to
the very sort of environment that we're
creating
by having so many people vaccinated with
a vaccine that
doesn't kill off the virus it actually
can lead to
more potent viruses try finding that
story anywhere
other than doctors i'm getting a phd
sending me these things
guys who won't speak about it publicly
because they're worried about the
blowback
people who are physicians people who are
even
even epidemiologists even people that
deal with diseases and viruses
they're concerned and they they don't
want to talk about it publicly
because people call them anti-vaccines
oh yes it's really wild
out there well it's wild because they've
somehow managed and i say
they meaning the political elite and
then i think their established media
representatives have somehow managed to
turn this into a political issue right
and that's dangerous
like it's dangerous for any politician
to play in that game
where they're using something as
meaningful
and quite possibly dangerous for the
country
as political posturing or virtue
signaling right
and you see it all the time because you
see these guys are wearing their masks
for the camera but then they take them
off aoc just got busted doing that
yesterday
did you see the video yeah
she puts the mask on and then takes it
off after the picture's done
yeah or they can have parties you know
what is it uh
you know how about obama yeah obama's
having that 700
guest
but you can't go to a gym
in new york right you unless you have a
vaccination car right where you can't go
out to eat we're gonna shut down small
businesses you can't go to a comedy club
uh and i think it's it's rules for the
and not for me
scenario and people read right through
that [ __ ]
because people some people i think even
plotting it
which is [ __ ] terrifying i know smart
people that are applauding it
it's it's so strange and the the problem
with applauding vaccine passports
this is this is part of the problem they
are not going to give that power up
no they're not going to they're going to
find a reason to continue to use that if
they can figure out a way to force you
into carrying papers into carrying
something that
lets you enter businesses or lets you do
this or lets
businesses open as soon as you give
politicians power
in any kind of power that didn't exist
previously
historically they don't relinquish that
power they find new reasons to use it
well i think that's the history of law
making and political power in the united
states
and i think that's why i i tend to be
bucketed
in conservatives because it means
smaller government to me
right there's there's multiple reasons
why people classify themselves as that
but i look at things and i look at the
preservation of individual liberty
you know how do i preserve more of my
freedom because i feel like i'm a
responsible adult and i feel like i'm
going to raise responsible
adults and i feel like i spend most of
my time around responsible adults
i don't it's such a disconnect
in individual philosophy when i
find people that that are actively
looking for ways that they can
forfeit their individual liberty and
hand it over to somebody where they feel
like they have
a better interest in running their life
than they do
and i understand the balance between uh
you know
we we have to have certain laws and
regulations that protect people against
you know overt dangers but i also
understand your statement where
i think politicians and i would say
lawmakers and
uh government bureaucrats have a really
hard time
relinquishing control once they have it
because it makes their job
yeah makes their job easier they can
just tell you to shut the [ __ ] up
do what i say and you have to you know
you can't work anymore
unless you do what i say that's
essentially what a vaccine passport is
right you can't do what you want to do
unless you do what i want you to do
i mean don lemon was talking about that
openly on cnn yeah
don't have a vaccine can't go to the
supermarket don't have a vaccine
can't go to work like it's so strange
that people want to say things like that
like that's the thing that blows me away
why do you why do people want
to because they're dumb they're dumb
they don't understand history they don't
understand human beings they don't
understand human nature
they don't understand the history of
every single
country that's ever existed other than
the united states
up until 1776 every
[ __ ] country that has ever existed
was run by
dictators right all of them this is the
first one
where you had elected officials this is
the first experiment in
self-government that actually worked and
it created the greatest superpower the
world's ever known it created the
greatest
cultural machine the greatest machine of
art and creativity
and innovation right [ __ ] here and
how did it do that it did it through
freedom
because when you give people freedom you
let people do whatever the [ __ ] they
want to do
they actually find ways to succeed and
grow and thrive
but as soon as you put the boots to them
as soon as you tell them you have to do
this
or you can't do that you have to listen
to me now you have
a mini dictator you have one step away
from a king
you have a one step closer you're moving
one step closer to dictatorship
that's what the [ __ ] is happening that's
what's gonna happen with a vaccine
passport
that's what's going to happen if they
close borders you can't enter new york
city unless you have your papers
you can't go to here unless you have
that you can't get on a plane unless you
do what i say
and people say whoa it's all about
protecting people from the no it's not
it's not because
we've shown this is a fact just a couple
of months ago
the idea of a breakthrough case was
unheard of nobody
heard of anybody catching covid that had
a vaccine
right that was the whole idea you get a
vaccine you have to worry about it now
we know not only do you get it but you
can spread it
and some people have died apparently
it's a small number i don't know what
the numbers are but i know that most
people who get vaccinated
when they do have the disease they have
a better time of it than the people who
are unvaccinated
but where are the people out there
calling for people to get healthy where
are the people out there calling for
people to lose weight
78 of the people in the icu for covid
are obese
78 where is that information being
shared
where's someone who's a leader who gets
on tv and says ladies and gentlemen
we've got to decrease our body mass
we've got to decrease our fat
we've got to make sure that people
aren't overweight we got to make sure
that people are healthy
walk around your block you don't have to
do something complicated
start drinking more water stop eating
sugar start taking vitamins
you can increase the strength of your
immune system we can fight
things off better we can be a healthier
civilization
better for everybody right you don't
hear a peep all you hear is
take this vaccine that doesn't even
prevent you from getting the disease
or you can't go to this to the sauna
wherever the [ __ ] you want to go you
can't go to the broadway show
it's madness it's madness it really is
mad it's because if it was a vaccine
that really is like a like here's a like
it's more of a treatment than it is a
vaccine really if you look at it
because you're saying you need a booster
now every six months
look if you get vaccinated for polio you
get vaccinated for the measles
you don't have to worry about it anymore
you're good this is not that
this is a totally different kind of
thing and it's a completely new kind of
vaccine
the idea that people shouldn't be
skeptical or nervous about that is kind
of hilarious
well it's kind of hilarious that people
won't
try on skepticism in general like they
need to be more skeptical they need to
push
people in authority and power and hold
them accountable
for their words and their actions
and there's this reluctancy i think
across the board to
question power either on both sides
right so it's like
the blue likes to question red red likes
to question right
but now you'll follow lock step in party
line
if one is saying something or the other
that's a [ __ ] problem
so to your point i was reading uh i was
reading
the history of the naspers indian tribe
and i've read a few books on this
just recently i'm from northern idaho
where where the nez perce indian tribe
ferocious people amazing like amazing
warriors
chief joseph was an incredible leader uh
incredible history but
it struck me there there's a there's one
chapter in the books that i was reading
about
how the u.s cavalry
they were putting the native americans
on reservations
for their protection and i'm not trying
to equate this in
direct correlation but this was part of
the narrative
because they were saying we want to put
you guys on reservations to protect you
from the settlers
and from uh retaliation so we want to
put you guys on this
you know 400 square reservation 400 mile
square reservation for your protection
and they're like dude
we want to be free i don't know what
you're talking about
and uh they go in and and they trace the
over thousand miles that chief joseph
led his
his uh his tribe through idaho and
montana
and then up close to the uh the canadian
border
but i couldn't help but think about
there's one
sliver of history in the late 1800s
which
in 1873 i believe it was which
was also connected to the the sun
of uh meriwether lewis was also part of
the the nez persinian tribe because he
had a son there
but i thought about how
us not us as a country how
we need to be pushed to ask more
questions and we deserve more
answers we have to hold skepticism i
think in a very high regard and we can't
beat it down i think any time that you
question authority
it's a good thing especially as a
society because it also says that you
have a healthy
society if you have this complex
narrative
you know moving up from underneath i
think the
the groundswell of information from
people you can have these complex
discussions but you also have to have
very good answers to what's going on i
think you've got
conflicting information that's being
politicized and it's being gaslit by
both sides of the media which i don't
blame people for being pissed off and
confused because
man i'm confused yeah like this is
confusing as [ __ ] the cdc releases
something
the president will say something else
some random governor somewhere that i've
never heard of will
say something else you're like what the
hell is going on
what is going on yeah that's that's why
i listened to uh crystal and sagar
because they
typically know what well they typically
know what's going on and
they're they're a great example because
that show breaking points
you got sauger who's on the right and
crystal who's on the left but they're
good friends
they get along well and they're both
super honest and objective
rational and intelligent and they can
discuss
all the finer points of these issues
honestly
openly and it's it's why they're
thriving
it's why cnn like some of their shows
their
some of their shows are they get a
hundred thousand views in the key
demographic
less than a hundred thousand even that's
crazy since trump is out of office oh
yeah
they don't have a boogie man their
boogeyman is on vaccinated people
that's what they're doing their
boogeyman is different different things
they can attack
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify